- [Instructor] In this video
we're going to talk about
measuring public opinion.
And the first question to ask yourself is,
why would we even want to
measure public opinion?
Well if we live in a democracy
where a public has a huge
influence on our government,
well you wanna know what they think.
And you could think about
the major institutions
in our democracy.
You could think about
people who are in office,
and they when they're making a decision,
they would love to know what
the public actually thinks.
One, they wanna act on
behalf of the public,
and if they wanna get
reelected by the public,
it might be in their interest to know
what the public thinks.
If you're in the midst of an election
and you want to get elected,
well you might wanna
know what does the public
think about you.
You might wanna know what are your chances
of winning the election.
How are your competitors doing?
Or maybe what position
should you highlight?
Or maybe which positions should you listen
to the public on?
Similarly if you're an interest group,
where does the public
sit on different things
or how does their
opinion change over time?
And a lot of what the media does
is help communicate to the people
what is going on broadly in our society,
and that includes what the
people themselves are thinking.
So now that we know that we
want to measure public opinion,
what are the typical ways of doing so?
You have the idea of a mass survey.
So this is a way of just
asking a lot of people,
you wanna randomly sample and say,
what do you think about some position?
What do you think about some social issue?
What do you think about
some law that is up
for being passed?
What do you think about
some type of candidate?
Now the next three kinds of
polls we have listed here
you could view as related in a lot of ways
to mass surveys or even a more specialized
type of mass survey.
You have the idea of a benchmark poll,
and this is where at the
beginning of say a campaign,
you see how people feel
about a certain issue
or a certain candidate
and then all future polls
you can compare to that benchmark.
Entrance and exit polls,
this is when people actually go to vote,
when they're about to enter
into the voting booth,
you ask 'em hey how are you going to vote
or right when they exit the voting booth,
they ask you, how are did you vote.
And people aren't obliged to tell exactly
what they did, but this
will give an indication
of what is likely to be the
outcome of that election.
Related to both of these is
the idea of a tracking poll.
This is a situation where
you might ask people
at the beginning of
some type of a campaign,
it could be a campaign for a candidate,
it could be a campaign for a proposition,
where this time you see okay
what percentage of people
are in favor of something.
So this would be the percentage in favor.
And this is time.
And then you periodically keep asking
the same group of people how they feel
about that candidate or that issue.
And so you're going to
be able to figure out
how people's opinions about
that candidate or issue
change over time.
You're going to be able to track that.
And then a more I guess
you could say focused way
of understanding public opinion
which might not be as
representative of the population
as a whole but allows you to
get more maybe more nuanced
then and more conversation
than these other four methods
would be a focus group.
This is where you try to bring
in a representative sample
of five, 10, 15, 20 folks
and have a discussion with them
about what they care
about and why they care
about these things.
So I will leave you there.
In the next video,
we'll talk about what
makes for a robust measure
of public opinion.